[Music]
so the idea really that you're advancing
if reality's a creative construct then
does that mean that physical objects are
hallucinations I mean Maria is already
distinguished between the ones that are
the hallucinations that are and then
things that aren't actually these
stations are you arguing them that
everything that we think is an object
before it's actually a construction
that's a great question so so the idea
is first that space-time itself is not
the pre-existing stage on which the
drama of life plays out it's a data
structure that you create when you open
your eyes you are the author of space
and time you're not just a little entity
stuck inside a space and time you create
it and every physical object that you
see is also a data structure that you
create imagine that you're in a virtual
reality you have a headset on as you
look over here you can see a
three-dimensional chair that you're
seeing as soon as you move your headset
over here you know that you no longer
render the chair you've sort of thrown
it away I'm saying that's going on right
now we all have headsets on I'm creating
the glass I just destroyed it the the
objects exist as we create them they're
telling us Fitness payoffs and how to
get them now the difference queen'
illusions the perceptions that are
illusory versus non illusory the
standard definition is something is
illusory if it doesn't correspond to
reality and it's vertical or true if it
corresponds to reality I give a
different definition something is
illusory this is now an evolutionary
definition my perception of an object is
illusory if it does not guide adaptive
action and it's truthful if it guides
adaptive action so it's a different
twist instead of saying it's illusory if
it doesn't correspond to reality I go
completely evolutionary I say it's it's
illusory if it doesn't guide adaptive
action so for example if I give you a
sugar cube you know from the 3d geometry
how to pick it up and how to use it and
how to put it in your mouth if you want
if I show you a neck or cube one of
these line drawings that's just a bunch
of lines on a flat sheet of paper but
you see a cube popping out that's
illusory
even though you see a cube it's illusory
because it doesn't guide adaptive action
if you try to grab the three-dimensional
shape you can't do anything so just
change truth for adaptive action and you
get the new definition of vertical
perception versus illusory perception so
for the can you explain a bit to the
audience this it this has then evolution
in mind you're saying that there's an
aspect to this this is about how we
survive and go on to create more than
humans that will then survive is this
the basis of your art that's right so so
this is now what I'm about to say next
is very very common among my colleagues
all of my colleagues will say that our
sense is evolved and were shaped by
natural selection that's that's that's
uniform so it's all about survival and
reproductive fitness where I differ as I
say knowing anything about the truth
will not help your reproductive fitness
so there's no selection pressures to
know anything about the truth this is
just what you get is a user interface
that hides the truth so for example if
you're writing an email and the icon for
the email that you're writing is blue
and rectangular in the middle of your
screen on your desktop does that mean
that the email itself the file is blue
and rectangular and in the middle of
your computer
of course not anybody who thought that
doesn't understand what the desktop is
for it's not there to show the truth in
this metaphor the diodes resistors the
voltages and magnetic fields it's there
to hide all that truth if you had to
toggle voltages to send an email your
friends would never hear from you so
what happens is you have a user
interface we pay good money for the
interface to hide the truth you don't
need to know the truth and yet you can
control the circuits without even
knowing that the circuits exist and
that's what evolution has done it hides
reality whatever reality might be it
gives a spy candy a user interface that
lets us control reality while we're uh
turley ignorant about what that reality
is but there's no selection pressures
for us to realize that so we take our
virtual reality to be the ultimate
reality I just want to ask you one more
question on this before I bring in the
rest of the panel so if we've heard lots
of physicists you may have heard them at
this festival saying that for example
table you know it's just comprised
mainly of empty space and so on you seem
to be going further indeed than the
physicists on this that's right that's
right you might think that I'm saying
something that the physicists have
already said Rutherford said you know a
century ago that this table might look
solid but it's mostly empty space
there's a nucleus and a like electron
far away and it's mostly empty space so
our perception doesn't match reality I'm
saying something different it's much
like what they're saying is much like
this I know that that blue icon on my
desktop isn't the real reality of the
file but if I get my magnifying glass
out and I look really closely I can see
little pixels and that's the truth
well no you're still in the desktop
you're still on the screen atoms and
electrons and protons are still inside
space and time anything the inside space
and time is just within your interface
it's not the objective reality I'll put
it this way
I'm not saying simply that our
perceptions get the shape wrong a little
bit or the colors wrong is that the very
language of space and time of shapes and
colors and physical objects is the wrong
language you could not possibly describe
objective reality using that language
just like you can't describe the
circuits of a computer using pixels of
the desktop cannot do it for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at III TV
you